for so many people in the pacific
islands climate change is more than just
a talking point or something to worry
about in the future it's happening right
now the sea level is rising and it's
affecting those who can't afford to do
anything about it
it's really affecting all of the family
over here like especially the when they
want to go to work
so mostly in the early morning when high
tide we have to carry our shoes in our
hand and then go to work the children
difficult to go to school during the
high tide every year the people in these
fijian villages see the water creeping
further inland and every year the
government promises to move them to new
land but nothing happens
just 15 minutes from downtown suva and
the five-star hotel where the leaders
are meeting is a different world all
together one where some of fiji's most
vulnerable are dealing with the reality
of climate change on a daily basis
pacific leaders say they want to develop
a plan to get more international support
and funding to counter the effects of
global warming we've contributed very
little to the to the problem so we feel
that
that it's important for those that are
responsible that they they do provide
that support through loss and then
damage but instead the main talking
point was who wasn't coming to the first
in-person meeting in three years
kiribati withdrew in protest against the
results of last year's contentious
election for the position of secretary
general of the pacific islands forum
an opposition leader is reportedly
blaming pressure from china
in may china's foreign minister wang yi
was in the region signing security and
economic deals with pacific nations but
beijing has denied putting any pressure
on kiribati
there is no factual basis for this
related report over the years china and
the pacific islands forum have enjoyed
good cooperative relations what i want
to stress is that china has never
interfered in the internal affairs of
the pacific island countries
the struggle for influence is likely to
remain at or near the top of the agenda
throughout this forum but away from the
meetings there's little or no interest
in the big names who have come to town
fijians are dealing with the reality of
a world changing around them and what it
might look like for generations to come
wayne hey al jazeera suva